alright are you ready to go let's do it
baby okay so this phrase was on it was a
the setup was a disaster same trash can
in the corner that's it I have a trench
here is that a frog because it looks
like was filled well same denim we doing
this doing the singing bike parking if I
give out afraid of singing Michael Minh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well the singer might stare at any time
as you know it's a great it's there
anytime anytime you don't need to sing
them I got so much [ __ ] up here now a
SpaceX hat with this nerd that I had on
the show I got my Harry Potter wand yeah
video games yeah yeah I got my candles
from hangover candle company which I
should light one right now by the way
you can turn me on to these guys because
I have been lighting candles and you
know this from being on the about last
night podcast I have candles going all
the time but I'm getting these Rite Aid
candles I like skittle flavored well
there it is he's gonna hear that and
you're gonna get candles in the mail oh
dude yeah because he is very elegant
style blonde
yeah uses like beer bottles and like
changes them around and all that kind of
stuff can you customize them that's next
dude comedian candles you know it'll you
know this out cuz I want to make that my
business model there's at least 10 grand
in that I just know there's something
right now yeah I felt I felt like I
fixed it and I was like I'm happy but as
I'm listening right now I didn't fix it
somebody sent me a tweet like Eric
here's how you fit is is a recording
latency issue yeah but it doesn't sound
like that what I when I listen to it but
when we're recording I'm trying to fix
that because I hear it right now it's
like I think what happened is when you
pressed a recording button that's when
something happens but anyways and I
still got the problem guys so I need you
audio text out there to help me out with
just not but before we keep continuing
further second time on the podcast as I
was saying during the singing mic
section he was on when I just started
one of my first guests here at this
place and I had like a weird setup but I
was just trying to be cute and now it's
like you know look at it now and he's
here again of the very funny mr. Adam
ray all right here we are we did it
I love it this this is a better setup I
noticed too I think it was maybe like a
week after the brick wall went up oh
yeah it was cuz of that episode I had so
many problems with your episode the
sound the look and I walked away being
like I like these podcasts and the video
but I mean like but I also knew because
you were just getting weird
so it's like like any good thing like
there's you got to go through the kinks
yeah this is funny you know you know
what just kind of like it's like you
know you you come to your friends with
like a shirt that you you know you're
like oh guys you like to sure
everybody's like well yeah and then like
later the guy goes you know I saw
pictures of myself and then that's what
everybody goes bro maybe we're trying to
tell you people do that how you are uh
you're one of the few people that tells
it like it is all the time though were
you always and sorry to flip this and
make this that's a funny interview and
you but I it's you know everyone looks
at people especially in their close
friends you know where I every time I'm
around you oh my god I want to get to
the point to where I can just you know
have a respectable filter but but
usually not have anyone you got to know
yourself well enough to know that even
if you're gonna go from here to here
real quick that you know you're reading
the room you know and you're not gonna
well okay so what a fat girl out for
being pregnant you know what I hear is
is how you handle criticism you know
that's what that's about it's about how
you neces don't necessarily like to hear
things and so therefore you go well I'm
not gonna do that to anyone else
whereas I yeah don't give a third yeah
because now by the way if you tell me
like hey man your constructive criticism
you not gonna learn all day even that it
doesn't even matter if you tell me like
oh you're a place your your thing well
it looks really shitty that initial
thing is gonna be like ooh you know yeah
I'm a process that fast and then i'ma
look and be like you know what you're
right this is shitty right and that's
just I just process it fast yeah so I'm
not it doesn't affect me like that even
if I have a reaction it don't affect me
like that so I go that's how I want
things yeah so then I present that to
everyone else like that
I'm also sensitive so you're right you
are yeah this is about you this ain't
about me it's about you and I'm doing it
right now
and how you doing Matt it's not like I'm
like you a [ __ ] better this away you've
got the best comedy [ __ ] finger point
by the way it's a little bit of a shot
yeah I couldn't run for president yeah
um but yeah so that I think the desks
with that but also I knew innately that
you were going to make all the necessary
changes so that's why I didn't feel it
was necessary to go out of my way to be
like no you need a brick
what's the wall coming in cuz the war
but got no it's not but we're not even
talking about that yeah what we're
talking about is the ability to have a
conversation with some see I don't even
think even if you see some constructive
criticism because like that's a that's a
nice way of putting like I had to tell
you some real [ __ ] so we'd like to try
to disguise that by saying like oh I'm
giving somebody constructive criticism
it's like no you're you're you're
telling somebody telling somebody
something that they need to hear yeah
I've been a few times in my life for
friends with like booze problems I've
gone out of my way and that was a big
deal but see you justified it in your
head why I'm because it's like oh they
got they had a booze problem so it's
okay for me to say that that's just a
testament to your personality you just
so you just like being a nice guy yeah
you don't mean you just you have you you
want to be presented that way and I want
everybody to feel good yeah I don't see
and I want everybody to feel good no
because after they get past this initial
thing so it's like I want you to feel
good about everything that's going on I
don't want you to lie to yourself you
know it doesn't make the compliments
more sweeter when you don't sugarcoat
the [ __ ] exact write that down put
on a t-shirt put it on the candle and
send it to Adam Wright comedy that's
where an Instagram yeah but that's my
thing though it's like I sweet or when
you don't sugarcoat the [ __ ] yeah
man that's exactly why but I always
always was like that when I was a coach
but you know you coaching kids and
whatever it's like that I'm not telling
you I'm not saying to you you doing good
no you didn't huh I know so yeah cuz
when I did say it you know I meant it
yeah you know what I mean so the kids
appreciate it more yeah see the parents
the parents know because you had parents
like hard on your really hard on Timmy
and you don't play them first of all yet
you still coach them dude how can you
coach a kid that doesn't even play first
of all the difference between first of
all parents are
worst you know like they're the hardest
to deal will you will smith kids you
know I'm just saying they're the worst
so like well added so adding a laugh
track number his rap parents just don't
understand Oh what okay that's what a
reference somebody who's forty everybody
alright so the no no like so I remember
do you having to do with parents in like
in dads and moms are also very different
who's worse out of the moms are the
worst okay okay moms especially moms
that are aren't sports savvy they're the
worst
okay all they're concerned with are the
kids emotions yes yes yes so like a dad
dad's just looked at I get a Jason
[ __ ] blows right no but even more
than that even if dad's upset if they
come into like you know be you know I'm
supposed to be starting you know I know
be quick fat but he's supposed to start
you know he's like you know so then with
a dad the kid goes out and [ __ ] up and
I could be like this that's your kid see
your kid that's why it's happening you
see Dad processing like I can't wait to
go on a weekend we going down to the
park and we go take you you know dad's
just they understand you know they they
have pride and the ones that don't those
are the ones that are like crazy anyway
you just can't deal with them right you
know but like mom's mom say [ __ ] like um
coach it was $75 for the team shoe
uh-huh why isn't Timmy playing you know
it's like they have no think well he's a
part of the team
right right and everyone buys a shoe he
can wear his own shoe but that's gonna
highlight the fact even more that he's
not a part of what's going on yet they
don't they don't get there you know I
have I've had mom say crazy things to me
back in a day it's like you know outside
they don't care they could they'll say
some [ __ ] like you know well that other
boys playing in Eppley that's how you
picked a team okay who got mother mother
father
you know it so it's like moms were
always worse and Alden Ellen can't even
read and you're gonna you're gonna put
him at the free-throw line for technical
foul shots that she wouldn't even know
that much but I can remember like a mom
telling me like before we started the
season she was like I'll never forget
this conversation because she's like
coach well what are we gonna do about
his grades this year you know and I just
gonna do and I remember thinking to
myself we yeah this is I said to her you
got six teachers homeroom guidance
counselor you hop out from two to five I
handle free throws and layups and the
other 23 hours of the day you parents
your child yeah yeah you know I mean
it's like this this like what are we
gonna do it's just the worst kind of
attitude well because coaches and you
probably displayed this you know you can
be a look for some kids a father figure
yeah an influence for sure and also
maybe a more stable your providing more
stability in their life or maybe the the
kid comes back and talks about how much
he loves practice in the coach in the
game so then that makes the and the
parent here's this connection and goes
alright well if you're this involved I
didn't get involved even more I know but
my thing was like it was a private so
they see movies they see coach Carter
they see [ __ ] you know and they're
just like you know but they the thing is
that they you know it's like it's like
she said how I said to her I was like
you know you pay ten six seven thousand
dollars a year for tuition I don't think
you paid that so the basketball coach
can oversee your child's education Wow
you would say that yeah because I know
this is gonna be a problem yeah you know
it's good in the book I have to nip this
in the bud to be like and I this is the
kind of what things I would do I
remember that because this is what
parents this is without on a perspective
out like parenting styles you know
different there's different parenting
styles because there was a kid he report
cards came out all right he didn't do
well he didn't do what his mom wanted
him to do okay
which was what
it was yes it was all A's whatever
whatever her expectation was that these
days whatever adorned with that a
building whatever it is so that we're
about to go out to play yeah it's the JV
team you know the kids are in the layup
lines are excited mom comes walking
across the court oh he's not playing he
got bad grades he's off the team
it's not gonna happen on my watch in my
mind I'm like your watch cuz apparently
you haven't been watching [ __ ] oh oh
think about yeah yeah you watch think
about it like so--you you're now getting
involved on report card day if you
getting involved on report card day you
ain't [ __ ] okay so don't act like you
know cuz here's what I don't like about
it you you taking the kid away from like
there's a certain responsibility there's
a certain aspect of what's going on with
the team that's like this ain't all fun
cuz my whole thing is like does he still
have a phone does he still drive in his
car did he still have a whatever game
system he has yeah is he still going out
on the weekend initially oh so once you
take away all that stuff and then we
could talk about a punishment or how to
do it if you're not even trying to do
your part if you yeah yeah cuz you know
if they take the car away you know how
to goon you know who's got to pick the
kid up that same lazy ass parent you
know it's like they want to like day
when they think that he loves this
there's ways to punish the kid without
punishing everybody on the team yeah boy
you should really think about hosting a
dr. Phil type show for analysts in case
you already got the mustache and the
[ __ ] finger points of the TV
you were wrong kid we'll be right back I
know it's called the finger Griffins
giving them a finger I don't know I just
think there's different styles there's
different ways to look at it but I just
do judge your friends the way they
parent yeah sometimes yeah even when I
was younger my friends you know I'm sure
when I have a kid I'm gonna be totally
I'll be the same way you ain't play but
it's like for me just to being somebody
that has had to see the results of those
now parenting be the you know outside of
it and it affects you because I remember
I'm like I remember having this argument
with my boy and my buddy you know my
buddy's dad who
when we were younger you know even when
I was like in in my 20s I still felt
like this so he the dad was gonna he
said I'm taking the TV out of their room
cuz I told him not to look at it at a
certain time and they're taking it out
and I said well okay I get it but that's
not really control yeah you know control
is the TVs in there and when you tell
them not to watch it they don't watch it
okay so that's real control yeah what
you're doing right now it's just you're
removing it and they're they all they
gonna do is resent you yeah this is all
just resentment hatred yeah so you know
that's just how I I just have like an
approach to this kind of thing and
especially like [ __ ] sorry ii especially
when it especially when it comes to like
i hate when that happens I'm not even
I'll cut it out dude you know what the
fans know that you take calls to man it
was dumb about it is I I have it on do
not disturb you know I don't understand
I'm putting it on airplane mode but
anyways you know it's like even as like
you know on the team I think I've even
told you this story before I don't know
it's funny with a podcast you don't even
realize if you're repeating yourself you
don't some so you got to write down what
this is what I was talking about to make
sure I don't talk about it again and I
may have sorry whatever there's always a
new audience there's always a new
audience listeners but like you know
when you do when you talk about building
a team especially with like young kids
this is two philosophies because you
know you have this society right now
wants it to be like you know everybody
should be on the team
yeah you know and I just think that I'm
I don't I don't subscribe to that what
do you think about just that aspect of
it let me get you in the conversation
short look I think every when I see
those videos you wrong you already going
with it so it's listen okay to be like
everybody should be on a team if that's
how you feel no I don't think that
because I look there was a kid in high
school named Dwight angle and he made
the Freshman team and he had decent
skills but he definitely was a like you
know they they put him on the team as
almost like a mascot yeah
yeah he we all tried to do that thing
where you get the ball to him to score a
bucket he'd never scored and he scored
and we carried him off the court the
game was still going there's a freshman
game it didn't matter
yeah you know but yeah he didn't make
the team JV the next year but I had no
problem with that because it was like
yeah there's this is now more
competitive we want to win there it just
there's only so many spots and there's
guys that are better than you
I do see those videos that are like on
Facebook or wherever of the kids that
you know have some true disabilities
completely different really that's
completely different
yeah okay so you know that's I I don't I
don't that'll count that is what I'm
talking about you talking about the kids
I'm talking about the kids this suck
yeah I did like get better I think look
I I know something someone can't get
better it's supposed to be a meritocracy
it's supposed to be like it's supposed
to be like you're your cuz we're
competing against other people and
there's a scoreboard yeah you know look
I didn't get I didn't make some plays I
auditioned for in high school or get a
certain part because they didn't think I
was you know so I and that definitely
stung I mean I should I didn't make
what's what there's like a select team
that I tried out for like this maybe 7th
or 8th grade for basketball and didn't
there was like three different select
teams and the one I made was the one
with not as good of people on it and I
was like really bummed about it and one
of the coaches who was a friend of Mines
dad tried to tell me like well there's
not enough spots he's like also like we
have already have a couple shooters and
they're like you know you do this and so
spots he tried to give me some [ __ ]
answer and it like stung but it
definitely you know made me try to you
know for a little bit anyway get that
mentor every summer I'm gonna walk in
I'm gonna dribble around the garbage can
I'm gonna do you know shoot every day
but but there is something to that I
think you have every kid's gotta that's
why it sucks because I got you know
teased you know when like in the quick
fat days and like as much as that was so
devastating and even I was telling a
buddy this day or day were he was like
how bad was I was like man I didn't
really know you know straight up like I
wasn't gonna [ __ ] take myself out but
like I had some [ __ ] dark thoughts
there for a little bit
because of that and it definitely has
shaped Who I am and definitely gave me
you know perspective and I'm I wouldn't
change I'm glad that I went through that
amount of like even though I would never
want to see you know one of my niece's
right now is is getting a little you
know bigger for age and part of me is
like [ __ ] like I want to step in to make
sure she doesn't have to get anything
that I got because it was so awful and I
don't want her to feel bad but do you
think that that's parenting though yeah
and then there's for sure and then there
but then there's a part of me that's
like [ __ ] like I know what it did like I
know how much stronger it made me how
much empathy it gave me and and this and
that so there's like I don't think there
should be then you're getting into a
whole conversation about like bullying
like should there should you never at
that age when you are so such a sponge
and have so much clay to be molded like
should you never go through anything bad
as a kid like you know that's what I'm
saying
it's a [ __ ] what here's the thing though
it's like you're to having the girls at
the skating party make fun of me when I
would asked one and them and hearing
them in the bathroom like make fun of me
dude I'll never forget that [ __ ] but
like girls are brutal yeah man but it's
but again I'm like you know I guess I
had a you know mom that you know would
pick me up to go back to and and be like
don't worry about them
calling you fat now do you want to have
spaghetti and meatballs dumped on a
pizza and wrapped in some Cool Whip and
there is no problem yeah it just goes
back to parenting right there yeah like
so some parents would be like well you
know get your big ass yeah I was very
passive-aggressive he goes for my bar
mitzva which is when I dropped lbs he
goes up I'm going back for seconds and
he goes you like seconds huh listen I
had this kid and then he tells me wait
he tells me he goes you know you can I'm
like mid-bite on my [ __ ] chicken pot
pies something that's just so good and
he goes you see me so salivating just
talk just saying the words chicken pot
pie
and he goes because you know you can't
wear sweatpants at your Bar Mitzvah oh
my grop like grandpa you gives you the
fork falling off the table
dude like that's a truth dart to the
heart man and but again like hearing
that from him
stung and I just kind of go and I was
like yeah and I was like again mid-bite
and I was like hey that's what you think
you know I'm like try to make them you
know cut through the awkwardness but you
need that people that's not you need a
village though yeah you need grandpa to
be like get your fat ass in gear and
then mom's supposed to come in and be
like it's okay you know grandpa's like
yes isn't that fat yeah and then you're
just like but you still heard that yeah
but you got this love and support did
you eat yeah that's once ain't it neat
it needs if you got none of that if you
have no bounds no balance you know but
that's the kind of kid that doesn't need
to be on the team
yeah but my point is is like you're
talking about a school full of like
however many they say if a hundred kids
try out for the team yeah how do I
determine who gets on the team the ones
that need it are the ones that deserve
it whoa can you take one of each that's
what ends up happening but see that's my
story for you is I remember this kid
Barlow was this name and he was he
wasn't the best basketball player okay
he just wasn't you know and but
everybody loved him so the kids were
like you know me a fun kid they come to
me like coach you got football on the
team they all did walking what are you
know the value that they thought he need
a locker room guy right yeah they need
the value that they thought he brought
was like not the value that they needed
when it when it came to it okay and this
is what as a coach what you're supposed
to do yeah you know what I mean it's
just like with the Cleveland Browns you
don't let the quarterback picked a coach
who just got into league yeah you were
the [ __ ] GM you go I tone it down
rookie we'll handle this yeah okay
so so that's I didn't do that but let me
tell you to my point of the story later
he's graduated you know he comes back he
was a cool kid he's around alumni game
he says to me I'll never forget it hey
why'd you put me on the team he was like
I know I was terrible oh [ __ ] but this
is what he said this is the part that
got me he said you know I was [ __ ]
have been on the team but then he was
like but when you put me on the team
that made me feel like I deserve to play
when I didn't play that made me feel bad
if I'm paraphrasing but that was the
point and I was like and and you know it
just reinforced in my head that I was
right all along
I rather a kid hate me for not making
the team than to be on the team and fail
and hate himself oh wow you know [ __ ]
dude because then it built this
resentment of like him being like
because he was on the team he's like
well why don't I play and I made the
team especially if I'm the kind of guy
that's hard so you feel like my word
means something yeah so if I'm supposed
to and then I didn't do I did him wrong
I should have cut him like you're not
good enough wouldn't be great if Barlow
was the guy that you like hit up he had
a construction business and you were
like dude I would be honored if you
would install put up like a brick wall
in my place for the podcast he's like I
got you and then he sent over this I
know but it's like so I always go let's
do that as that example by the way says
it all I know and it was it was another
one here's another one this other kid
I'm good on one but I think there's a
little kid I forgot his name but like it
was I remember this because he was like
report cards came out yeah sweetie the
kids were ineligible to play it was like
one of those things you know so I mean
as a education coach I'm terrible
reprioritize like kids doing their
homework okay so that's all me yeah
we've addressed it move on okay but
anyway so we playing a game and like I
have to get these bench guys and this
one kid he goes in and he just oh man it
was a disaster it was a close game
you know Travels turn the ball over it
was just a nightmare after the game he's
sobbing you know privately comes to me
he lost the game in my mind I'm like
yeah you did but at that moment your
travels you didn't even dribble you just
ran with the ball like you were trying
to [ __ ] it was like just a moment
where you go okay here's the moment
where you you balance you go okay it's
time to be hard it's time to be strong
with an animal though I'm not an animal
so yeah after a mouse
yeah no no but I was like but in my mind
I was thinking as he's talking I was
like this is why he shouldn't have been
on the team because he wasn't ready for
the moment yeah and if you're not ready
for the moment what the [ __ ] are you
doing there and that's on me and Leslie
Mann Edwin McCain song
these are the moments this is what
you're supposed to got this thing in my
case it could just completely [ __ ] it
up yeah I'll do it again these are the
Mamas only God knows I love these are
the Mamas pretendin oh my love oh god
all I'm waiting for yeah that was our
high school that was our high school
yearbook no end of the year assembly
senior year when they do the slideshow
Chris was the voice oh my god
seeing someone just looking and just
like not even acknowledged actually I
would watch the voice if it worked like
that oh they're turning around because
they like facing that's just but anyways
you know getting back to it it's just
like you know how so this gets crying
and you did what you gave him a I gave
him a pep talk like no listen it happens
you had a rough one now this is gonna
this is why you should practice more
this is why you you know so cool sad you
know but it's like in my mind I go it no
matter what this kid does he's never
gonna be good it was just that kind of
thing and you gave him false a false
sense if I had to give him a fault yeah
I had to because in that moment it's
like it what's the point he's already he
blames himself for the for the loss so
I'm like okay good
he acknowledged that how he fine
so I don't need to pour salt on the
wound but this is one of these moments
where you have to think about the
overall picture so and what I'm saying
is that's why I am the way I am
sometimes it's because I'm trying to
help in the overall picture so like when
you came to me and you're always you
know I'm talking about workaholics and
I'm saying things about like you know
this isn't always the best situation
your mr. life from my perspective I'm
looking at you like okay we'll see how
you an Amir you know you an Amir with
your life because all I'm trying to do
is prepare yeah yeah totally stay
neutral right yes yeah you know my buddy
Ben you know you know Ben C word yeah
you know Ben yeah look he's gonna love
I'm talking about a great kid yeah I
should just have a mom but you never had
him on is it great he he made both songs
from my specials and he made the song I
made his Montez you know for I made a
song i've made an R&B song as my
character on workaholics I do remember
that and you'll remember the song to do
special it was just the the just the
intro music oh great okay he's great at
that but anyways what the [ __ ] wasn't my
point about bringing up what you were
saying oh yeah I guess okay so he was up
for her he was up for our sitcom you
know Ben was Ben was up for this stay
calm and he was like just the way he was
talking about he was like they love me
you know he just was so hyped and I just
remember saying to him Ben like it's
great yeah that they're saying all this
but nothing matters
Wow I watch you book the job okay like
all this stuff they're saying like don't
I'm saying is trying to don't get
yourself so excited off of like
Hollywood words yeah because the
Hollywood types know how sensitive
people are and they're worried about
like you can also there's so many things
that go into even I mean the amount of
stories that I've heard or experienced
myself where the like dude they love you
they got it there
is waiting to get the off that's what
those things nothing is real until it's
real and even when it's real it's not
you could get fired at a table read so
I'm telling him this and he's like oh
he's poked a push back was heavy yeah
you know nobody would say you know you
know just the way he was so like and I
was like okay I just and he and and and
by the way not only did he not book it
but those people that were saying how
great he was yeah I don't know if he's
ever had that experience with them again
like it's not like they were like you
were so great so we're bringing you back
were you when I got the job right it's
not just no that's not what it is
because it's a very subjective the
business yeah so I know that so that's
why I don't listen to anything yeah
because it's subjective it could be you
know one of the executive producers
who's the money person comes in and she
goes that guy that nose and mustache it
just looks like my second grade teacher
that failed me that kind of [ __ ] those
are goes into it so it's not it's not
all based off merit and talent yeah
skill a lot of it is all these things
comes into play so because those things
come into play I say don't listen to any
of it okay now how about with comedy
like do you feel like if you see
something you see somebody run the light
before you at a club this happened to me
years ago and I called the person out on
it and because I was so just compelled
it was so bonkers to me that it was
happening
and it was somebody that you know yeah
there's there's also a little bit of
probably like there you know what four
or five years you know blow me as far as
like how long they've been doing it but
but and and somebody didn't show up at
the store they popped in and did you
know almost ten minutes over the time
which was so crazy to me and it just
pushed that place yeah and I pushed
everything back and look there's only
count them on your hand the amount of
people that can truly do that yeah a
store right and I go don't say anything
what is it really gonna do they're not
gonna change their ways and I go you
know [ __ ] it
but they walked right by me and tried to
give what's up but not in a super
Pleasant way so so it didn't really kind
of squash the the feelings and then I
just
when I went out in the hall and said
something to him and wasn't receptive at
all and then I was like see I shouldn't
have even done it because what was it
gonna do you know but it was so by the
way yeah it wasn't for that person why
you did that
what I was doing it for you that's the
thing about those situations yeah like
when someone wrongs you you're not
necessarily telling them so you hope
that they go oh you know what you're so
no no I know I'm just saying I'm saying
like you needed to do that where are you
you need to let people know hey I don't
appreciate that yeah and please don't do
that and if they don't take it that way
it don't matter
you've you've put it out there yeah and
if it happens again now you have a
precedent to be like yo bro
yeah remember when we talked about this
yeah you did [ __ ] again yeah I feel like
you disrespected me yeah but you now you
have grounds to be like well there were
seeds planted it's funny you say that
because like there have been an instance
probably a year prior where this person
had tried to take road work from me from
when I was with a certain comic opening
so there'd been so yeah so there so
that'd are gonna be searching the
calendar I wonder what he was working
for Ontario December 2015
so there already been some seeds planted
to where it was like I'm sure there was
that added ammo to me wanting to be like
I haven't taken a shot yet maybe I
should do it now you know yeah I get you
know I'm not I'm not faulting you for
being like you know it's like you're not
you're not you don't want to be
combative you're you know I know how I I
know how I feel it's like you know again
I I knew how I was gonna feel after that
I don't like to be contentious or have
any sort of hate in my heart because I
know just how it makes me feel and I
know I'm not at my best if I'm walking
into any situation with any sort of
animosity or weirdness I'm fine with
that kind of stuff you are huh yeah
because you know where I stand
yeah you're not gonna you're not gonna
you know it's like it's like I like
people that know me like that so so like
if you come to me if you come to me and
go you're not coming to people oh yeah
if you come to me and go Eric I wrote
this script and I really would like you
to read it yeah if you do that to me I
know that you want the truth yeah so at
that point that's why you came to me
yeah so you've probably already shown it
to you
sister your cousin and and your manager
who's giving you like [ __ ] notes
yeah when you come to me I know it's
like all right you know do you want and
that's why you do it in with the finger
so I'm just saying that's just like I've
just established myself to be like that
I just want to be in this and I'm I'm I
what I don't know what I don't
appreciate what I take offense to is
this idea that like I don't care about
people's feelings or I don't care about
like you know it's that's people that
just don't know you enough but they only
get one piece of you right but that's
just in that I just think that's people
projecting their own [ __ ] thousand
percent you know you're just saying like
you know whoa I don't you know and I and
that and I get it I know it that's what
I was saying like it's funny that I use
that example of when you and a mirror
got on that TV but yeah I don't think
that like especially with a mirror I
don't think a mirror and I actually
became friends until he went through
that cuz that's the moment that he could
be like oh oh I see what you were saying
yeah I get where you're coming from like
it did I can't talk to somebody who's
not on TV and complain about TV yes your
dream I just want to be on TV yeah and
I'm just trying to go I don't think
that's true yeah there's things that go
on behind the scenes there's things that
everybody it's all relative like I
always say to you before like if if
Chappelle Chris Rock you know all these
people that got paid 20 million dollars
or sitting at a Denny's I guarantee you
they're they came and they said how was
your experience with Netflix they're
gonna be like oh man you know let me
tell you what happened to me and we and
we're sitting there going are you
[ __ ] kidding yeah yeah you made 20
million you know but that's just guys
one more ketchup or is that yeah but for
them they could be like it wouldn't give
me free tickets or it's just a different
level and so that's why you end up you
end up migrating towards people that are
near your level on your level or or
someone you see is gonna be on your
level or and even surpass you yeah you
know what I mean and you have to be able
to like you know it's like for me I'm at
a point now in my career where I just
like I get I'm a journeyman I'm going
around I'm starting [ __ ] late I'm doing
a podcast I'm trying to get [ __ ] going
but
I just did some dates with Dane you know
and you know there are he was surprised
when I was like cuz I talked about it on
my podcast yeah I was like yeah I said
to him because he was groaning the tour
I was like I'd love to come do some
dates and he was like the look on his
face was kind of like you know it's like
hey man you know not most people aren't
like that yeah you know cuz I'm like I
headline clubs but like he's selling out
arenas yeah I'm not taste of that 3,000
people aren't coming to see one of my
shows at one time so I'm like yeah you
know a lot of those people are gonna
know you so it's just like extra what
3,000 like reuptake a lot of people this
won't have any ego about that I know
this is what's so crazy - there are so
many people there's so much content
Devine was talking to him recently about
is special and and him getting back to
clubs and he's like yeah just don't got
any material and he told me it's one
story I go well there's a five minute
story right there and then I go also you
just need to get a get some reps and and
right but then he goes if I and he goes
I can't tour yet because I I got a
retire the hour I go retire the hour I
go dude I go I love you but you can't
assume that everybody saw your special
yeah
you just can't unless you are truly at
that level but he's doing like big
feeders and stuff a thousand percent but
there but you haven't done them all
haven't done every city I know who was
it was I think it was Kevin Hart
that was like Duke going to all these
finding arenas and all these smaller
towns and just [ __ ] cleaning house
with an act that he hadn't that after a
tour he done but he hadn't filmed it yes
Sebastian makes it completely known oh
yeah you're gonna see the act that you
saw and some new stuff right but like
that's the whole you know let me ask you
something I got no problem with that -
have you asked Adam to be on your
podcast yeah he's done a bunch Adam
Devine's been on your pocket balance I
podcast he's probably done five times
solo oh I haven't even even and cuz I've
asked him to be three times for tour
recaps where we and those are the great
ones cuz that's where we just kind of
see I asked him to but recently did you
ask how he's for Jesse yeah no no just
to get any he's a little podcast out
big time yeah well he he told I actually
go you know I'm gonna go through I
always just go through him but I was
like I'm gonna go through his publicist
cuz I know he's got a lot of [ __ ] going
on yeah and let me just go this way
she's like he's not really doing any
podcast right now and then and then also
index Sheppard's pops up and he's on it
and I was like not doing any baggage
yeah but also if Dex you know two
million listeners whatever he's got yeah
but my whole point is like I was trying
to like yes sure I mean yeah I should
have happened I'm saying you're not
doing it for you yeah you're doing it
for me I did yeah that's why Blake came
on yeah on ders came on in Chilean came
Marybeth came home Kyle came always said
he's the only [ __ ] from the
workaholics cause she hasn't come on yo
you know what I mean the finger dude you
got called out man you got a boy on my
phone jexy tell Adam it's like it's like
he's so he's so funny about that kind of
stuff can you are you guys gonna
Clippers games you know what this year
it's like to watch I didn't Jack the
prices up but just my situation I had a
lot of personal [ __ ] going on and I
wasn't sure and then when we got Kawhi
Leonard and what you call it all of a
sudden ABS like yeah you don't want to
[ __ ] it's like it's a before I know you
know so it's like and I'm like you know
what I thought about the cost and I was
like I'm about to buy an electric car oh
wow yeah dude I'm like me I just
priorities gas yeah I know dude I didn't
realize how much my parents live 50
miles away girlfriend lives 30 miles
away you know my brother lives 30 miles
away and I just was driving all over the
place I looked at my gas bill three days
ago and I was like 250 to $300 a month
holy oh yes and I was like that's it so
I get to tell much credit how much for
the battery plug-in well they're getting
it here they're getting it into my
building they don't have it yet so I'm
just got to deal with it until then you
know but this place is all over a
charging station right yeah and I said
to myself this is gonna be in a way that
I'm gonna be like I'm gonna write comedy
I'm gonna be like alright I need to go
charge my car and I need to sit look at
my material
like I'm gonna make it a thing myself
you know I mean I didn't have a car for
two weeks and I was oberon everywhere
Ryan man I almost didn't like my car
yeah the shop I almost didn't what
attacks people are saying that like so
much done dude with children these ubers
it was crazy man like seriously and he's
self-driving cars so we could just be in
that little cab and doing [ __ ]
well self-driving cars it what here's
here's my old thing when it went wrong
and like first of all one of them killed
a woman at a crosswalk in Tempe and then
another one like drove off the freeway
into an embankment and I was like cool
guess I will continue to drive myself
always in forever but robots ain't do
that one of those else one of those
anyone would have killed that woman that
one woman that got killed
she was amazing that woman was just like
in the wrong yes she's a wrong place
wrong time
yes Jim if it wasn't that crosswalk
she'd walk into a yes she would have
walked into a Radio Shack where I shoot
up happened or something no no no that
woman was mentally ill that's what I
this is what I was known as a normal
woman cross that was it was something
was up with her and she if she walked
out into the to the anybody would've hit
her so the robot was doing us a service
he was like oh this person should not be
they did a quick calculation you know
when that when that robot takeover
happens well after seeing Whitney's
robot I was like yo dude after I seen
Whitney girl but I was like oh the sex
robots aren't ready that [ __ ] looks
nothing like her I know dude it's like
it's like it doesn't it doesn't I mean
it's like look it's for a robot but
that's robot it looks like a person we
want to say robot we want the sex robots
to be like it looked like Jessica Alba
you don't mean like it feels like
Jessica Alba
it looks like Jessica Alba but I mean we
have no basis for comparison so like the
like if you're feeling robot Zoe wait we
do have a basis of comparison real
people yeah that's the comparison real
Alba is where I'm saying no no it's over
here if you get the robot Alba and
you're like oh we get to test and you're
like yeah come in send in real album you
know
for the case study I just I don't know
if it's gonna be in our life company you
don't think I don't think it's gonna be
in our lifetime what happens first
uncanny like robot sex dolls where you
were we're not even calling them dolls
we're like other extra sex people right
well you say people instead of BOTS okay
first of all it's coming let me stop you
okay
no the robots are gonna be that's just
gonna be a feature on the robot it's
like if you have a car and it has a
reverse cam yeah that's not the main
feature of the car but it's nice to have
a reverse cam okay
the sex portion is gonna be like that by
the way what's gonna be like bucket
seats
what is the reverse cam in a car what is
the what is he equivalent of that in a
sexpot it's gonna be a heated video I
don't know listen you know listen to I'm
saying they're not gonna know they're
not gonna be sexbots they're gonna be
right now it's gonna be downstairs
cooking right clean in and then you know
it's like okay you know what let me go
to sex mode and then like the problem is
right there being made for that what's
the equivalent like you said in a car
like the reverse cam as an extra feature
so the sex is the extra feature but what
specifically just being able to have sex
if you want to have like you know it's
like a - like a nun toothy blow job like
what's the reverse cam equivalent I'm
trying to explain to you see a robot is
you just really want to go with that
joke that's what it is he's like trying
to shut down our throat say I'm gonna
get just joking everybody I think
there's a there's something there and I
want to finish you know I'm telling you
that the robot is really gonna be for
more practical purposes okay
like they're making those robots are
being made they're trying to finally see
what's happened is gonna make a robot so
we'll fly cable no guy is gonna start
playing out their fantasies may I go
that cable no no no this here the robot
that's gonna come first let me give you
a better example do you see black mirror
I loved it okay they made this video
game and it's a fighting video game yes
and then the feature on it was you can
[ __ ] okay but it was a fighting video
yeah which to me is ridiculous like if
you can [ __ ] that's the station
like that was the stupidest part of that
thing it should have been this here's
the [ __ ] game and if you wanna fight you
can't the dumbest part of the right a
little but what I'm saying is they're
making robots right now like the you
know what's gonna come before the sex
box but it's gonna be the mechanic robot
the barista robot the like the robots
that can carry [ __ ] and like deliver
stuff look cuz they're not gonna lose
delivery robots I'm not trusting a robot
within 15 feet of my place they're not
gonna look like but you trust like
Johnny who like can't pay his rent
that's why he's delivering GrubHub yep
no [ __ ] I know Johnny's not gonna come
up my stairs a burrito and Austin go oh
no no Johnny's gonna come and be like
hey what's up Adam raised yeah nice yeah
that's the guy that's gonna come back
with his friends cuz he knows where you
live they don't do background checks on
GrubHub delivery guys just come to your
house
you mean ubereats they don't do back
everyone there's never been to prison
yeah what are you talking about those
Marines you got changed it over beats
[ __ ] my point is oh no robots that are
gonna infiltrate society a lot of
strangers have seen my house are gonna
be they're gonna be practical robots for
purposes now the thing is the the people
that are trying to work on sex robots
they're trying to get them to look as
real as possible for hope for them or
for us for further consumers because
that's what you want I don't want it you
know what you know what this is I don't
think that's what we want though the
peoples that are buying and investing in
sex robots or remember the fleshlight
remember who was it I think I did a red
band Icehouse Billy a long time ago
they're giving them out and I was like
dude there's no way I can ever willingly
do this like I was curious couldn't do
it and I would say if I did it or not
but by the way it did sit in the back of
my Ford Escape with bungee cords that
were holding the bumper on my old horse
just falling apart and when I pulled
into a lot one time for an audition and
they had the security truck and back
there you know it's doing a lot of
sketch at the time
I had agent not an on I had a puppet a
fat suit with like it was like a
stripper fat suit with this like big
stripper titties and like this weird
like garter belt it was a fat suit for a
sketch and a puppet and the fleshlight
and the security guard opens my trunk
holds up the fleshlight in the puppet
and i'm in the rearview mirror going
over my sides I'm like yeah looking all
nervous and she goes let me guess do you
single and I was like she's like you
gotta get this joke at I'm getting this
joking right now okay let me give you a
better execs dolls and investing all
this stuff they aren't getting it for
their want the feeling they don't care
about the look listen listen mmm
no I disagree with you I'll guess it a
lot of people that get sex robots are
people like amputees or people that are
like shut-ins
people who are like they they have
social anxiety just the fact that
amputees are the no no I'm saying people
that have some kind of issue with
themselves and don't feel right you know
that are buying sex dolls yeah but but
like look like if you're like eh if the
sex pot looks like a model you know I
mean that cuz you're like you're not
gonna get a real model with our amputees
buying other amputee sex dolls no of
course not why would you question I
don't know maybe we want somebody looks
like you but no point and I don't know
if these facts are true I'm just saying
[ __ ] yeah but here's the thing though
anyway she just cut to that I don't know
clip every podcast cuz people I listen
to a lot of what you say be like is this
valid no no I actually had a discussion
with someone else about sex robots okay
and they were talking about like the
types of people who get sex robots are
not what you think it's not just it's
what only perverts that get sex robots
well that'll disagree with you no I mean
let me begin exam saw you running for
office in 15 years me like it's not only
perverts to get sex dolls and once I cut
the mic no but they're gonna give you a
better analogy about what I think about
the sex robots and how they look and how
they're not quite ready yet because they
don't look like human beings and ready
for who standard can I finish yeah
they if I'm gonna get I don't like sex
with the looks of these sex robots
because they look like plastic dolls
you've never been attracted I've never
you know
ever looked at a Barbie and be like
what's going on tonight yeah so but what
I'm saying is when if we settle the
people that have settled is like the
people that settle for mp3 sound like
mp3s
is a lower grade of sound than the WAV
format that used to be on CDs right but
kids and all the downloading and things
like that they don't care right they
don't know that because they don't
appreciate the difference right so
that's what's gonna happen with this low
level sex dolls out there but I'm saying
it's like it's not gonna really take off
until you know it looks like how it
looks in the movies that's how we want
it to look imagine let's say you're
Jessica Alba and this is what you would
be this what's gonna happen this is the
future Jessica Alba is gonna be able to
but put an era Griffin is probably not
Jessica Alba because by this time she'll
be like 47 year-old Jessica no but like
even what she'll be able to still want
that doll but listen listen she'll be
able to license out her likeness so
you'll be able to be like do you want a
Jessica Alba dog you know how people say
on a prince original oh you're right so
she'll be able to like you know it'll be
a whole thing you know she'll be until I
she'll have the big scissors and like
you next or you wanna [ __ ] a Picasso
reprint right exactly so then so then
she'll like you know and then this would
be a cool thing though like what if like
alright so she has a sex doll and then
you can like to pay a little extra you
know there's like she asked for an hour
a day like actually like remote like she
has on like VR glasses and so the guys
like hi so how you doing and she could
talk through that whoa but you don't
have to worry about it cuz she's just
like I think I'm gonna say some weird
[ __ ] like where you could only see from
like above us we have to listen instead
of if you listen you hear what I'm
saying so you want her voice in the head
she's actually controlling this like she
have to look she can control the sex
doll yeah so if the guys like y'all put
your left hand
in my butt and she's like oh you sure
you're not the right one yeah yeah you
know what that it's more interactive
would have to really be her like like so
this is the future of it is like so
there's a room like II like she still
you have to Adam sex dolls you know what
I mean and you just have a room full of
like you know people who are like
talking they're controlling the sex doll
from like animatronics oh yeah yeah yeah
Dark Crystal like guys who ran the mouse
and made them go like yes I think so
they're like you know so you don't have
to worry about the AI you just have some
remote person doing it I'm a big fan of
this you know and that's how it's got
the billion dollar industry waiting but
see the thing is until they look and
feel real or people just gonna have to
settle I think I don't think we ever get
I mean dude look at the graphics in in
like NBA 2k you know right oh I don't
you're saying they're so good or have
you played Modern Warfare no bro
is it unreal it's just it's so on it's
crazy
whoa but we're all we're not there yet
and but by the way too I think that
we're gonna bypass the whole sex doll
industry and go right to its gonna we're
gonna go right to like brain stimulation
the sex dolls just gonna be like cool
and then you're just like giving a cheer
like this you know just coming you know
it's gonna be like the matrix oh my I
think that's the future like I keep
saying like imagine imagine like that
technology comes into play so then your
apartment this won't your apartment will
be like this this chair like you'll be
in a big building with like a thousand
people cuz your apartment is gonna be
you sit down you having a feeding tube
and you're gonna going home and you're
met I live in the Taj Mahal you know cuz
the VR world is gonna see lines you ever
see the movie the surrogate what Bruce
Willis no it's just that like people
would go into their pods yeah and they
would live these alternate lives that's
what I'd come home and they literally
get in this pod and they were it was so
real you gotta watch it dude but that's
the future I think it's gonna be we're
gonna bypass all of this like all that
stuff your pod yeah you're just in your
you know you know you have to put like a
dick thing on
you know something goes in your butthole
for like for a lot of purposes and if
there was feeding to but you're just in
a thing and that's your apartment and
people come over they interact you know
you're interacting and you're like you
die in your alternate world I don't I
don't know yeah maybe that's gonna be
the side effects you know so good that's
the thing they tell you they got a
warning label but that whole thing
whoever started that room it was like if
you die in your dreams you die for real
remember that I don't remember that I
never heard that that was like one of
those weird playground yeah what do you
even call that saying that just like
it's not an old saying it's good but
what I'm saying dreams are real I'm
saying like yeah you have a dream you're
in this dream and then like you wake up
and you're like AHA what the [ __ ] just
happened
whatever that space is in your brain is
what they're gonna have to access access
what's the science nerd talk with a
little perverse what's the most real
dream you've had in the last five years
I don't remember them you don't drill I
I do but I don't hold on to them like
like I couldn't like I couldn't access
it right now but I have had some times
where I'm like whoa you know you wake up
and you're just like oh man what you
know I I always find it like I wake up
like white when you're supposed to like
in the dream something's happening we're
a cycle I need to wake up right now
I almost feel like just like some
alternate like you know where they're
like your body's like recognized your
robot your body tells you like or
whatever it is
oh yeah I definitely had a dream once
where I was going down on Katy Perry
and remember that the original iPhone
ringtone that was a guitar like Dan and
Dan then when you eat her all of a
sudden happy for that that I would have
welcomed what he did that it was so then
there was a guy in a corner because my
phone went off so am I going down and
it's so real
I can't even believe it's happening I
don't even know what spawned this dream
or how I got there I wish I could
remember like the
what led to it like what preceded it
like if I met her on this raving and we
went to like a fair like what did I play
out to build up or tonight literally
because your control your dream
so did I literally just bump into on the
street and go oh sorry and then my dream
cut to me like you know saying play out
a whole scene so then the phone goes off
the thing and I come up and I look over
and there's just a guy in the corner
playing guitar and then I woke up yeah
those are weird that's weird [ __ ] but
can you imagine though you see her like
how many people dream about oh I'll tell
her that dream you know if that's what
you're asking
let's see here because I've had people
hit me up and tell me weird [ __ ] like
Yolo be like Montez you in my dream last
night and this happened you know and I'd
be like okay cuz cuz if you're if you
watch something a lot or you're a fan of
something or something's in your head
and all of a sudden you're just like
yeah you know you do people have weird
dreams yeah so I don't know I just feel
like the technology to access whatever
that is in our brain that's the future
yeah yeah [ __ ] dude
I'm gonna weird I got to get in the
gaming world so I can you know talk [ __ ]
to you on Twitch yeah you actually guys
make sure you follow my new gaming
channel it's gonna be cut it's called
err Griffin gaming you know it's
whatever title there's too many Griffin
gaming's oh yeah yeah you'd be surprised
I looked it up and I was like I am
surprised and there's so many I was like
and I used to be like so they click on
your profile and then that would happen
no no no I'm just saying I would just
say that while I was playing oh you know
so I just love how old are the people
that I don't play against you do you
remember when the first like headsets
even came out you could play the wool
from all over the world yeah that blew
my mind dude
me too dude I met you know what's funny
about that is I actually became fried
egg is of war now the first year Gears
of War came out you were playing like on
a team you have four people okay so then
you would just
just would turn on and then you start
playing at people like hey I'm from
Ireland you know who'd be like and I met
these dudes from Europe and we just
started playing all the time to the
point where I was like we actually
became friends you know and I was like
this is amazing crazy but the problem is
is like you didn't sometimes you end up
and there's like it's clearly a nine
year old yeah I think that's what the
creators have chatroulette
intended member but then I just turned
to do a fanfare of dicks I you know I'm
saying they were like maybe people from
all over the world can meet and and
click and see someone just pow a dick
just how much dick is on that you know
I'm gonna be great to find out if like
the guy who created chatroulette also
was like the like the stepson of the of
the guy who like invented Snapple you
know but here's a problem with the
chatroulette
is that a lot of is everything no no but
the thing is because men are so dumb
we'll go through 75 dicks for the one
titty you know what I mean
cuz it's in Bosnia and you're like you
ever seen the titty pop something you
like look at the dick comes into this
Creek anyways we've got to go to dinner
I'm glad Adam ray came on even though
you he big-time me you know you also
big-time he was here just be honest I
just I [ __ ] up yeah but so look I
don't know tell me you but you told me
since there's no excuse you said you put
it in your calendar wrong and I know
that was [ __ ] no it's not I swear to
God who sent you a calendar invite
didn't read it so I think there is a so
you don't take care of business I have
my schedules organized chaos dude I
email myself like my [ __ ] for the day
but then I also have just gotten really
good and guess what things do slip
through the cracks sometimes but when we
were scheduling this I there were like
two other podcasts a day and of my force
over job and a meeting and I locked
everything in in a way to where I just
was so fixated on this is this this is
the important things to you know this
was no I remember I was gonna go podcast
12:30 so I can go meeting it too cuz I
go 12:30 1:30 gets me at 2:00 and then I
go
Erekat what was it for for yeah
everything you hit me up at what time
403 like are you almost here yeah
and then I [ __ ] up yeah you bastard
yeah yeah I'm not really recording just
because of that I'm not even joking dude
we loosely joke about the quick
everyone's doing game shows now I know
it would crush a game show dude I just
want to be on I want to be the Family
Feud guy I want to take it back him we
get that out there you'd be so good oh
my god
so that would be the show if they
literally came to you with a slate of
games and they go hey man pick one you
wouldn't go prices right
you wouldn't go jeopardy price it no not
jeopardy cuz that would feel stupid all
the time not jeopardy not Price is Right
cuz it's just you know the banter you
got to do a show I'm thinking of I'm
taking a wheel of fortune yeah I would
do prices right yeah that's right would
be fun well it's real fortune there's
not a lot of you know it's you're asking
the [ __ ] questions and you you have
to keep it moving cuz you gotta get to
the game gonna be fun with people prizes
right you can do that price is right if
you you can spend you know two to three
extra minutes and they'll cut a
commercial break if you have some funny
banter with somebody you know I love
that also doing contestants row that's
crowd work maybe in the front row hello
who doesn't take advantage of that man I
see Judas be like how that money makes
your bait you're getting it's a it's
crowd work city dude people are running
down an aisle to the front row and then
you basically can just be like you want
to be up here [ __ ] and just you know
I know I get it so you know maybe you'll
see me on the part that's when I've
completely given up Family Feud they
don't give a [ __ ] they can I love family
feud
but Steve Harvey's just hilarious he's
always so dirty and like is he dirty
yeah and I always love how it see then I
don't if they set this up on purpose but
it's always like a black family and a
white family like 75% of time it's like
the Jackson and it's just like a race
war going on and see Barbie always takes
sides right like he's like if you'll
rallies [ __ ] up he's like
okay but then he's like you know if the
Jacksons missing she's like come on I
know you know the answer next up Jameela
Jamil the versus steward jameelah always
knows what the answer is gonna be
because it's so dumb questions but
anyways guys we're gonna be done this is
Adam ray I'm gonna have all this
information below he's got speak for
yourself how does not speak for yourself
what's the name of the podcast about
lesson I was thinking of this show as
well just be free so about last night
podcast I'll have all this information
below I had to bring them back on
because the setups different and so you
know I also have here yes yeah plug some
[ __ ] go ahead man
so I've got a my stand-up album is out
read the room film to the same frame
punchline but I'm coming up to everybody
listening going like this dude I love it
I have my comedy music album coming out
oh my god dude all 13 original songs
I've sketches Sandler style and I'm
gonna play the the promo right now it's
1 minute long here we go
[Music]
leasing of the Goo Goo Dolls just
singing on the track oh that's good
well you should have told me about this
park then I could have just put it in my
thing so it's not just weird awkward
puppy cut away from this
I don't know that gonna stay in just the
case so thanks for coming on the back I
love you thanks for having me man
that's at Adam rate comedy on Twitter
and Instagram he's got a comedy album
coming out and we have a bunch all this
information will be below oh you put it
right here so can I do like one of those
what again I don't really know it's
really down below but I might do that
I'm not Rick Glassman that guy he has
like to [ __ ] a fix the production value
on his nose you listen to that one take
your shoes have you done it yet yeah
yeah oh yeah it's great he's a fun guy I
saw him the other night we were talking
about doing it again like doing some
kind of crossover episode oh yeah I'm
gonna go back on but get really bait to
them you don't smoke pot though dude
yeah he'd be so fun and your gaming yeah
you would dude
people say that cut to like I'm on the
news if I killed someone
okay we'll not be smoking with Erik
Griffin anytime soon in the near future
alright guys thanks for listening and
I'll see you next week